et bien bonjour bienvenue dans diagonale
la leçon alors aujourd'hui une leçon
avec jean-luc chavanon il notre
consultant grand maître bonjour stéphane
lui leçon sur comment gagner les gros et
puis parce qu'on peut gagner à y croire
et bio il y avait donc la finale royer
pions contre roy c'est finalement le la
finale la plus importante à connaître
donc quand on sait quand on connaît les
maths élémentaire quand on se battait
avec une dame puisque rois des pions
qu'entre roi ne peut pas ne peut pas
donner un math direct il faut que le
pion à riva d'armes ou à tours où à tour
on peut même faire tout c'est exactement
dans les maths élémentaire d'ailleurs on
ne montre pas le mat d'armes puisqu'en
fait la dame n'étant plus forte que la
tour la technique est encore plus simple
on préfère laisser chacun de découvrir
qu'on sait que ça se fait encore plus
vite qu'avec la tour tout simplement
avec la même technique
oui c'est quand même mieux de faire la
pièce qui tient la plus puissante de
façon moins puissante
la troupe a oui la toile à tort si on
fait la moins puissante la plus
puissante qui peut le plus peut le moins
comme on disait c'est assez courant
alors évidemment avec roy et pio il donc
il faut faire une promotion
voilà promotion autour ou honda millions
choisit en général choisi dame mais ont
tous choisi retour s'ils ont envie de
s'amuser et pour faire re a des fois on
peut faire râler adversaire exprès ça
arrive j'ai envie que si on fait des
parties où l'adversaire par exemple ou
pour alors qu'il sait qu'il est parti
donc qu'il a perdu il vous par
énervement et bien l'adversaire peut
aussi encore plus les servir lui-même en
retardant l'échéance au maximum ça peut
arriver ça oui ça arrive mais en général
ça arrive de
moi puisque quand les joueurs
d'expérience eh bien ils ont un plaisir
finalement à conduire a terminé la
partie avec du matériel en plus giron
fait une dame on m dames en plus bon bah
on prend son temps
alors on va montrer tout de suite une
position classique de finale
roy et y rencontrera alors ça peut
gagner mais attention ça gagne pas
toujours
c'est à dire que même souvent ça fait je
sais pas si presque du 50 50 c'est soit
parti nul soit gains pour les blancs
enfin pour ceux que pour le club qui a
le plus en plus en l'occurrence les
blancs ici et là par exemple dans cet
exemple qui ont tout de suite c'est
justement pour expliquer que ça gagne
pas à tous les coups si ton noir de
jouer et on va voir que les noirs en
prenant la fameuse opposition dont on
parle souvent dans les leçons la fameuse
opposition 3 vont empêcher les blancs
gagner oui tout à fait vrai donc ça
c'est une position assez intéressante
puisque si cet honneur de jouer
la position est égal et si c'est aux
blancs de jouer la position gagne pour
les blancs moi c'est vraiment une
position de base et la leçon dont 2
cette position c'est simplement la règle
de l'opposition vraiment la chose que
nous allons pouvoir apprendre
alors on va voir ce que c'est que cette
fameuse opposition cet honneur de jouer
donc le coup qui fait nul évident parce
qu'on choisit toujours le meilleur coût
pour le camp l'analysent et bien tout
simplement voilà c'est ce coup là ici et
on voit qu'ici il y à la fameuse
opposition des rois ils sont ils sont en
position et l'un comme l'autre ne
peuvent pas passer mais c'est donc le
roi noir qui bloque le roi blanc
c'est une chose très importante je
n'arrivais d'entraîner à des à des
jeunes des jeunes joueurs qui sont qui
sont assez sportif et j'avais utilisé
une technique pour leur expliquer ce
genre de final qui est assez marrante
c'est une leur parler de tout simplement
de rugby par exemple
oui je leur parle de rugby où je leur
explique que finalement quand on a un
jeu à plusieurs
quand on a un jeu collectif il faut
faire participer tout
enfin faut que tout le monde participe à
l'action hélas en mettant le roi en face
du roi adverse on empêche le roi blanc
participer alors juste pour montrer si
au lieu d'être le roi sur elle cette si
on avait posé le roi sur l'a 15 17
voilà qui est une erreur les blancs
jouent secouent leurs attentes donc le
roi blanc montrent pour le matin je peux
pas le montrer tout de suite il faut
juste que je fasse une petite manip
voilà c'est fait donc le roi blanc
montrent le roi des sens là on obtient à
peu près la même position mais là c'est
le roi blanc qui est en opposition face
au roi noir le roi noir doit quitter
cette cette symétrie pour aller soit à
gauche ou à droite silva à gauche par
exemple le roi donc se pose sur la case
f7 et là on constate que le roi
que ce roi sur un f7 contrôler ces trois
cases voilée c'est à dire les cases e 6
e 7 et 8 c les trois cases qui vont
permettre au pion aux pions qui est sur
la case donc le 5 d'avancé jusqu'au bout
jusqu'à dames et là c'est terminé c'est
à dire que les blancs n'ont même plus à
bouger le roi du tout le pion va bouger
jusqu'à dames et les noirs ne peuvent
rien faire les noirs sont complètement
impuissant face à l'avancée du pion et
ça donc cet exemple ça illustre
finalement cette image sportive que
j'emploie avec certains de mes élèves
alors on va revenir juste dans cette
position de l'ue on va voir pourquoi ces
nuls donc on essaie de gagner avec les
bleus
donc on pousse le pion avec échec voilà
bien le roi coll
il faut coller absolument et maintenant
l'europe oblige il défend le pion sinon
il le perd et c'est mais c'est nul
hélas dans ce type de position un seul
coup pour les noirs vous pouvez le
vérifier par vous-même un seul coup
permet de faire nul
il ya trois coups à leur disposition des
noirs ici ici ici alors c'est facile
c'est le coup symétrique
donc c'est celui qui va en mythe puisque
si on joue sur une deux autres cases et
bien on perd là on perd la partie on
verra tout à l'heure on perd la partie
en pole position
on perd l'opposition alors que
maintenant quand les blancs essayer
d'avancer le roi est bien on garde
l'opposition évidemment évident on ne
ferait pas la grosse erreur d'aller de
l'autre côté puisque ça reviendrait à
l'exemple que j'ai montré tout à l'heure
puisque l'aca permettrait évidemment
d'avoir ce fameux exemple ça y est on
contrôle la caisse de promotion et on
peut plus empêcher le pion d'avancé
alors il faut évidemment prendre
l'opposition
voilà ici why fuites donc plus qu'un
seul coup maintenant pour les blancs au
moins de recul et on a on peut toujours
reculer mais dans ce cas là on revient
coller un tout simple exactement les cm1
pose ici c'est la même position donc sur
une répétition de position aux échecs on
le rappelle ainsi trois fois la même
position c'est nul moi j'avais être nul
très rapidement aussi up échec roi 8 est
maintenant le seul coup qui permet de ne
pas perdre le pion pour les blancs et
bien sûr aussi c'est là ses pattes
il n'ya pas échec et laurent ne peut
plus bouger donc ces parties nulles
voyez donc là le roi ne peut plus bouger
ses parties nulles
donc là on a bien compris pourquoi il
fallait
il fallait faire l'opposition c'est que
dans tout cet exemple si on reprend du
début jusqu'à cette position là le roi
blanc ne participe pas à l'action et le
roi blanc est derrière le pion il est
impuissant on ne peut pas accompagner ce
pion et donc pour ces raisons il ne peut
pas empêcher le path qui qui arrive à la
fin alors on va maintenant passer à une
autre position est en fait qui est une
position extrêmement classique les
paramètres qui vont bien à ces voix la
position classique et là alors là par
contre ça va être ça va être un peu
lancé la grande position qu'il faut
connaître très certainement cette finale
pour comprendre tout le mécanisme qui
permet de gagner avec trois pions
c'est aux blancs de jouer dans cette
position et un seul coup pour les blancs
gagne alors on sait pas on peut pas
deviner quand ils en font vraiment
connaître la technique parce que si on
connaît pas c'est très difficile de
savoir quels coups gagnants pour les
blancs oriana il y en a qui feraient nul
tout de suite évidemment ce serait eux
deux quatre skippers le pion en faire
simplement et avec 2 3 on se retrouve
avec l'opposition la fameuse opposition
donc en fait ce sont les blancs doivent
prendre position et qui doivent en fait
pour gagner finale de pions c'est cette
finale puis on les voit qu'entre roi ce
qu'il faut comprendre c'est qu'il faut
préparer le chemin du pion c'est à dire
on peut pas il faut pas envoyer le pion
à l'abordage tout de suite il faut les
préparer le chemin il faut contrôler les
chaumes le chemin du pion si à un moment
donné on ne peut plus contrôler le
chemin du pion en amont c'est à dire
devant lui eh bien on gagnera pas la
partie donc le seul couple y est il faut
jouer par équipes
de toute façon il faut jouer à plusieurs
dont il faut jouer faut faire participer
le roi blanc à l'action il faut faire et
voilà le coup ces trois le coup curieux
puisque on passe devant le bio c'est sa
part hier non naturelle et on fait ça
l'est parce qu'on prend le positions et
on va voir qu'on va préparer on va
mettre le roi sur ces cases annexes et
on va préparer ce chemin ici devant on
va empêcher le roi noir de bloquer on va
manoeuvrer pour préparer ce chemin
arriver jusqu'à demain on va le voir
tout de suite les noirs font ce que les
mots rejoint cool qu'ils essaient
d'autres avaient déjoué un conte qui
perd le moins de terrain possible bref
ce à quoi la hélas le coup mais voilà
c'est celui-là c'est 3 des 4 et voilà
regarder on a préparé le chemin du bio
mais attention il s'agirait pas de dire
on va préparer le chemin du pion et
c'est bon c'est gagner non parce qu'on
n'est pas encore jusqu'au bout donc il
va falloir travailler encore pour
préparer ce chemin alors par exemple si
les noirs faisait l'erreur de jouer en
f4 et bien il s'éloignerait un petit peu
de ce chemin par exemple on peut le
montrer tout de suite su roi ici f4 et
bien là et n'ont plus joué le coup et le
4 on voit que le roi déjà ne peut plus
revenir
donc le chemin de banques y ont ils des
bills est complètement ouvert on va
aller simplement l'accompagné avec le
roi en restant symétriquement le roi
noir ça va être très facile à gagner ce
serait une grosse erreur pour le noir
évidemment devenir la voix le roi doit
le roi noir le roi qui défend doit
rester en phase ii du pillon et en face
du roi adverse
il doit donc dans cette position le roi
noir voir revenir sur la case de 6 alors
effectivement rois le 6 et maintenant il
faut pas se tromper puisque si on joue
ce coup et bien ce sont les noirs qui
prendrait l'opposition face aux blancs
empêcherait les blancs d'oeufs d'avancer
et de préparer le chemin du pion et si
on jouait ce coup là bien on aurait la
fameuse opposition qu'on me voir tout à
l'heure voilà donc que les noirs restent
en face et attendrait donc ils
attendraient jusqu'au bout avec le
fameux pad du fonds exactement
donc il faut pas jouer ça il faut
continuer à garder l'opposition alors
quand il regarde l opposition et mais on
a gagné du terrain on était là tout
alors maintenant on est là il est en
maintenance il est noir metal un jour de
l'autre côté et bien up refait la même
manoeuvre la même chose de l'autre côté
également l'incroyable sac qui contrôle
la case e 4 e 5 et 6 donc pour le pion
donc ils préparent encore l'avancé mais
un tout petit peu plus loin alors 3e set
donc toujours la bonne défense m leroy
en face du roi adverse et en face du
pion pour pour le bloquer le plus
possible alors que 4 serait encore une
erreur relève 7
on aurait opposition et ça serait
terminée donc il faut encore et oui
toujours pas bougé le pion mais prendre
encore une fois l'opposition
le fait le plus longtemps possible on
essaie d'aller le plus loin possible de
façon à se ménager des
deux pions qui peuvent servir de coude
attentes quand la position sera un peu
plus mûr
on croyait vii normal on leur prépare
regarder le chemin qu'on a préparé pour
le pion regarder ça si c'est pas beau
c'est beau et maintenant il est
peut-être temps pour les noirs ils ont
compris que s'ils allaient laon il
allait encore se prendre une position et
que ça y est ça serait finie donc ils
vont essayer de te perturber les blancs
ici on joue en croire des six puisque
maintenant vrai que chez les blancs si
le blanc si les blancs ici d'aller
prendre encore du chemin ici up est bien
le roi noir va bouger sur la case e 5 et
on pourra plus empêcher la prise du pion
- donc il faut éviter aussi d'aller trop
loin
faut bien calculé son coup les lignes
étant maintenant il est temps pour les
blancs d'envoyer la sauce voilà on peut
jouer aux quatre puisque le roi noir ici
est dans l'impossibilité de prendre
l'opposition face au roi blanc
cette opposition là n'est pas n'est pas
là n'est pas valable puisque le pion va
dans cette direction il faudrait être
ici et on voit qu'il est trop loin tu
dois le roi noir doit doit redescendre
leur descente sur la casaque cette voie
là et là problème
la problème tout de suite parce que si
les blancs essayer de garder ici en
jouant ici on va le montrer tout de
suite garder ici le chemin du pion est
bien le roi noir des videmment ne
descendrait pas ici puisqu'il a serait
perdue le pion ira dame mais il faut
montrer et à on peut pas avancer les
pions
donc il faudrait revenir avec le roi et
aurait un risque de répétition
il y aura une répétition et les forêts
trouver la solution au coup d'après donc
il ya un seul compte dans cette position
c'est le groupe est bien aux cinq en
avance encore le bio on voit toujours
que le roi noir ne peut pas aller dans
le
en position durable ans et après 3,8
il faut reprendre l'opposition et
surtout pas évidemment joué le coup eux
six puisque l'entrée de pâte quand même
me montrer le pat e6 est là ça serait ça
serait une grosse erreur puisque euros
l'opposition est prise échec
roy huit rôles de 6,06 à battre voilà
voilà
la partie annuler la partie nuls donc ce
serait une grosse erreur que de bouger
le pion d'une case et le bon coup
évidemment c'est toujours pareil de
reprendre l'opposition devant le roi
donc très important là c'est vraiment le
thème clé de la position roi epyon
contre roye prendre l'opposition de dans
le pion ménager le chemin du pion très
important il faut comprendre le
mécanisme
sinon on va perdre beaucoup de parties
en fermera pas les points qu'il faut
dans les moments cruciaux
oui c'est que le pion à quand même une
manoeuvre assez limité alors que le roi
peut aller un petit peu dans toutes les
directions
donc il faut profiter de cette pièce qui
est quand même un petit peu supérieur au
niveau de ses déplacements
là maintenant on constate que si le roi
noir va à gauche
le roi blanc donc va monter à droite et
le monial on va montrer tout de suite va
le montrer c'est si mais si
si le roi noir choisi la caisse de
droite par contre ce serait de l'autre
côté j'ai donc symétrique will et les
solutions sont symétriques de toute
façon donc trois rois des huit points 18
97 et là ça y est on à la fameuse
position qu'on a vu tout à l'heure avec
le chemin le chemin quand c'est
complètement préparé ça y est on a
réussi voyez à préparer le chemin est
maintenant plus rien ne peut s'opposer à
la marche du pion 3d cet échec nous
devrons peut pas prendre le pion puisque
le roi protège par des huit échecs le
roi par usec d'am-dam ou tour comme on
veut
de toute façon évidemment en 2002 me
situe non là c'est pas un match nul
c'est plutôt une position gagnante
voilà mais on a la position finale donc
si on revient donc
si on revient un échec et après mon
match facilement avec roy et dames on
peut juste revoir un tout petit peu le
la position dès le début donc voilà là
on donc on place laurent en face du roi
adverse
on prépare l'opposition pour pousser le
pion donc ce qu'on a vu le roi doit
redescendre on leur met en face leur
revient là on essaie de ré accompagner
le pion donc on va essayer de
raccompagner donc le pion ici sur ces
cases leroy revient à nouveau
l'opposition
donc le roi-père l'opposition on prépare
à l'avancé des pions le roi attend on
fait la même chose
le pion avance le roi se met en face si
votre position s'il revient la danse et
dans ces cas-là on peut accompagner
directement le pion jusqu'à dame tout à
fait donc dans cette position le roi
doit venir sur la case 1,8 et l'a à
nouveau l'opposition très très important
et il n'y a plus qu'à accompagner curé
d'ars voilà alors on va on va maintenant
passer à un autre
un autre exemple de c2c final rien
d'envoyer il ya les petites subtilités
on gagne pas à tous les coups donc il
faut être extrêmement précis
donc on va voir maintenant une petite
subtilité voilà on est on est dans cette
position est alors dans cette position
7o blanc de jouer et on se dit ma foie
abi tient même si on n'a pas réussi à
préparer le chemin du pion mais c'est
une exception
oui dans la seine exception c'est qu'on
n'a pas préparé de chemin du pion mais
ce qu'il faut regarder quand on a une
une position il faut regarder donc qui
est très loin des classes et oblongs de
jouer voilà six états au noir évidemment
les noirs prendrait l'opposition à la
suite pendant l'opposition concernant le
roi noir viendrait donc sur la case f8
le pion à vent serait donc d'une case
angers7 le roi noir reviendrait sur la
cage g8 et le roi blanc n'aurait que
cette case g6 où elle est et ce serait
pas ce serait pas comment bien de le
voir donc comme ce n'est pas le cas là
les blancs vont pousser les pions et le
roi noir donc va devoir fuir la casse de
défense la case de promotion il va
devoir fuir la casse de promotion le
pian contre les deux seuls autres 15
voilà donc en venant sur h7 est là il
n'y a plus qu'à accompagner le pion
jusqu'au bout pour faire dame
voilà donc le roi le roi s'en va on fait
dame et la bonsu regard de la position
seimat très très vite le roi doit
revenir ici et c'est un échec et mat
tout à fait voilà donc cet exemple pour
montrer que qu'il faut quand même
regarder la position systématiquement et
l'exemple suivant alors on va montrer un
autre
notre exemple qui est qui
attendez un exemple avec le pion le pion
tour oui oui on va je suis dingue de
seconde parce que je dois faire des
petites paramétrage donc voilà donc
qu'on doit aller montrer voilà cet
exemple là cet exemple là qui est le
fameux exemple du pion tour voilà donc
l'exemple du plan tourne alors par
rapport à la position qu'on a vu tout à
l'heure on a décalé les pièces d'une
rangée sur la droite
donc là tout est là on avait un pion qui
était tout à fait ça là on n'a même plus
haut sur la colonne j'ai ici un g6 là on
l'a mis en page 5
voilà donc ça c'est le fameux pions tour
voilà le pion taureau qui prétend h ou
en a donc qui peut être de l'autre côté
et dans ces cas là ce qui est très
important à retenir c'est que lorsque
l'on à un roi et appelons tour comptera
roi on ne peut pas gagner on peut pas
gagner si le roi noir arrivent à
contrôler la classe de promotion c'est à
dire qu'il faut qu'ils les diamants si
le louvre a été loin ou s'ils n'arrivent
pas à temps on peut toujours empêché le
one world allaient dans le coin mais si
le renard ne peut pas havas dans le coin
alors ça y est il a réussi son pari et
il peut sauver la partie on peut montrer
tout de suite donc l'opposition prend
l'affiché en mai leur one world mais pas
être délogés exactement dont pascal et
voilà c'est en tout cas ce qu'il
faudrait aller ici il faudrait aller sur
la case ih 7,7 à 1007 les classes comme
sa série 7 on comprendrait qu'on
préparait chemin du bio en or les trois
cases ici contrôlée sera avec le roi sur
cette case il cède qu'on ne voit pas
puisqu'elle est enrichie qui il
s'agirait d'un jeu d'échecs fait voilà
ce qui signifie que ce qui signifie que
finalement que le
que le format du jeu d'échecs dans
certains cas permet aux joueurs qui
défend de se sauver de ceux de s'en
sortir
tout à fait alors donc mais on voit que
donc donc on est obligé de revenir au
centre et simplement les noirs attendent
et on peut rien faire on est obligé de
pousser le pion jusqu'à faire ce fameux
pattes
voilà voilà que l'on voit donc ça c'est
l'exception aussi du pion tour si le roi
noir arrivent à contrôler la caisse de
promotion et bien c'est terminé alors on
va maintenant montrer encore un dernier
exemple sur sur ce thème qui est un
exemple
donc ça c'est un exemple pourtant
pourrait très bien su revenir dans une
partie de compétition puisque là on a
toutes les pièces qui sont qui sont sur
l'échiquier donc ça pour être issu d'un
milieu de jeu compliqué tout cela il ya
quand qu'il ya un cavalier et une dame
oui les noirs contre une dame un fou est
un pion donc le chemin de la victoire
pour les blancs n'est pas si simple si
ils ne trouvent pas la solution
voilà c'est trouver la solution alors on
le montre quelquefois dans ses leçons
peut-être s'il faut il faut toujours
garder ça en tête si vous savez si on
sait si on sait gagner à partir d'une
position est bien comme on vient de le
voir par exemple avec roy et pions si on
sait gagner si on a bien compris le
mécanisme est bien on peut se lancer
dans ce qu'on appelle des
simplifications
c'est très important et d'un grand
joueur qui tefana de ces simplifications
jean-luc c'était le chant tout le monde
tape à blanca oui donc capable en
quelques hits est un spécialiste du jeu
au final et donc qui est qui aimait donc
simplifier les pièces de toute façon
c'est mathématique a aussi une règle
très simple donc je vais encore prendre
l'exemple du rugby où on pourrait
prendre le football cette fois ci on est
une équipe qui joue avec avec 12 12
joueurs du sportif contre contre onze
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué que s'ils
sont 3 contre 2 puisque l'espace et le
rapport mathématique est beaucoup plus
important ça fait peut-être on peut
montrer cette position voilà donc
position donc là il ya 4 4 participants
contre 3 voilà l'idée c'est la
simplification mais tout simplement il
faut noter que si on échange les pièces
ici d'abord avec échec
eh bien on pourrait la dame pour y
reprendre vous prendrez du fou tous
récents échanger et à la fin le roi noir
ça aurait ici et le roi blanc est là et
si on arrive à calculer qu'on sait
gagner cette finale et on va le montrer
évidemment et si si on va réussir à si
on arrive à calculer qu'on sait gagner
cette finale d'après les royalistes
convient de montrer et bien faut pas
hésiter il faut le faire il faut il faut
entrer dans quelque chose de sale parce
que sinon ça va ça peut durer des heures
cette partie et voire même un peu même
peut-être perdre parce que d'un
mécanisme très puissant et sam hamad à
piagge 7 la faire des pieds et pour moi
laissé dans sa position pour le moins
laissé la possibilité à la dame noire de
faire un échec sont g5 et de tenter un
échec car pénible faire des chèques
perpétuelle on peut faire on peut il ya
beaucoup de choses et puisqu'à rallye
peut être très dangereux avec dd c'est
souvent dangereux quand d'azf note dames
et cavaliers quand on est embêté notre
salaire qu'il nous reste très peu de
temps ou dans une partie blitz c'est un
véritable cauchemar même attention il
faut être sûr si on échange donc si on
prend ce cas faut être sûr il faut être
sûr qu'on va transposer dans une finale
roy pions contre roy qui est gagnante
car si ce n'est pas le cas eh ben ça
sera beaucoup d'efforts pour rien
exactement d'avoir et bien les blancs
tout calculer et il sort en islande 1
simplification d'un prend cavaliers
échec évidemment on est protégé par le
fou hein on se lance pas dans une perte
de gamme donc les noirs sont quasiment
sont obligés puisque évidemment si les
noirs par exemple venait manger c'est
comprendre elle adapte simplement alors
là on a un fou de plus alors là on n'a
même plus besoin des clés l'opposition
etc
le fou pourra toujours gagner le temps
qui nous manque le temps nécessaire un
coût d'attenté on aura la position que
l'on souhaite donc c'est très facile de
gagner avec un fou évidemment on n'en
parle même pas donc il faut échanger fou
prend pour apprendre et voilà la
position qu'on calcule et les blancs au
départ de leur sacrifice fin de l'heure
de leurs échanges soit la bonne
sacrifice puisqu'ils ont eu un échange
de pièces
ils ont calculé cet échange d'un doublé
voilà je vais entrer c'est sûr parce que
la fin je s'il a gagné c'est
mathématiquement même face à kasparov et
viège la gagne les mêmes traces a dit
bluesmen me fasse à vos plus grands
ordinateurs de tous univers je la gagne
idra
même face à idra associe hydrate riches
s'ils transforment les pièces ne sais
pas quoi mais sinon il peut pas et la
technique et les scènes je prends
l'opposition je ménage le chemin du pion
et attention faut pas se tromper puisque
si on va sur la case f cadre est bien
ici on ne la prend pas on l'appelle on
la perd puisque ce sont les noirs qu'ils
apprennent donc il faut pas aller sur
cette case là donc réflexion quelle
autre case les biens tout simplement la
case g4 et là on à l'opposition en
diagonale voilà c'est la poussée
hormonale et on va voir que suite aux
coups des blancs voient le coût des
noirs pendant vingt-six maintenant ce
sont les blancs et ses eaux noires de
jouer et pas les moeurs
face à ce grade et donc on va pouvoir
comme on a vu tout à l'heure accompagnée
le pion jusqu'au bout et on va le
montrer tout de suite entre les six et
bien hop on gagne et ça y est le petit
chemin dans ce ménage le petit chemin
pour le pion et noirs ici reviennent sur
la case of 7
on va prendre position toujours
important et a pris 27 ans aux ménages
le chemin moi aussi je peux essayer de
pêcher en eaux troubles
exactement au cas où le roi s'aventure
un petit peu plus bas mais bon est-ce
que sinon évidemment suroît fuite on
aurait encore repris l'opposition en
juin
va pas s'gêner d'ailleurs on peut le
montrer un peut-être montreront est
fluide tout simplement on reprend
l'opposition et suite à voir s est alors
on peut choisir de pousser les pions
c'est pas bien grave puisque les noirs
s'ils reprennent l'opposition hop on a
regardé aux jouets le pion donc il faut
calculer les coups de pioche qui peuvent
servir on en parle est un petit peu tout
à l'heure le roi de bouger à gauche ou à
droite dans l' essai à laisser terminer
sa fameuse position on peut plus
empêcher le pion d'avancé on revient sur
le petit exemple avec au lieu de ici
plutôt réussissent donc l'art dans ce
cas là on bouge le pion au f4 roi f7
maintenant on pousse le pire on aura une
suite et on reprend l'opposition donc on
arrive à la même position au g8 roi de
7,3 g cet échec
en plus le pion et ensuite ces dames et
s'est facilement matt évidemment là on
vous invite à retrouver la leçon sur les
maths b retour contre roye ça suffit
pour savoir comment tu es comment bâtir
autour trois rois dames votre roi c'est
le roi dame contre 3 ans à plat tout est
simple c'est la même technique que
qu'entre les tours alors eh bien je
crois qu'on arrive au bout de 7 de cette
émission chargée en uc alors très
important je crois qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui peut-être une finale qui
arrivent le plus souvent ça arrive c'est
très fréquent cette finale devront être
mieux contre le roi
ça c'est ainsi fréquent non ça c'est
fait partie des dépositions élémentaires
qui arrive le plus fréquemment puisque
souvent une partie de compétition
l'effort joueurs
optimise en exploitant un avantage
minime mais davantage minix a peut être
qu'un pion oui c'est souvent on s'est
souvent appuyée souvent les joueurs un
pion suffi pour gagner donc donc il base
son club stratégie finalement sur
l'avancée de ce pion qui se transforme
en dame à la fin alors à noter que dans
les parties de grands maîtres comme ils
savent ils savent pertinemment que les
grands maîtres entre ça va très très
bien mater gagner ce genre de finale ils
vont même pas jusqu'au bout et il
abandonne même avant quand la position
et gally par l'adversaire oui sauce par
énervement il ya toujours des joueurs
qui jouent par énervement il veut jouer
jusqu'au bout
sabrine on va dire qu'il jouait un petit
peu le début de la finale pour voir si
l'adversaire a bien compris la technique
tout à fait voilà donc terminé pour
cette tension trois pions contre eurois
très important à travailler là aussi
entraîner vous mais face à un adversaire
tout seul ou face à un ordinateur
l'ordinateur davantage c'est que ces
patients et ça vous embête rappaz à
bientôt